HARRY AND THE HENDERSONS
IS LEGIT.
- NO, WE SAID IT WAS LEGIT.
- WHOA, YEAH, HERE'S MY BIRTHDAY
PRESENT THAT I GOT YOU.
- OH, DUDE.
- I PUT IT IN A BOX.
- THANKS SO MUCH,
EXCEPT YOU'RE LYING.
I HAD THIS NEXT-DAYED
LAST NIGHT.
- OH, THAT'S A CHOP.
[laughs]
- WHO WANTS TO DO A SNIPPET?
- I LOVE SNIPPETS.
- UH, ACTUALLY, WE--
- WITH THE WHIPPETS, RIGHT?
- YEAH, IT'S A WHIPPET.
PEOPLE COMES TO SNIP ITS SNOUT.
- WHAT IF WE JUST, UH, DUCKED
OUT INTO THE BATHROOM
AND GOT DRUNK LIKE USUAL?
THAT'LL BE FUN.
- NO, WE ARE MAKING MEMORIES
AND THEN DESTROYING THEM.
- OKAY, NO.
THAT IS HIPPY-CRACK, MAN.
DID WE NOT ALL CRY DURING
THAT STEVE-O DOCUMENTARY?
- RELAX YOUR MIND,
I'M GONNA BLAST OFF.
- OH, WOW!
[laughs]
WE'RE JUST CELEBRATING
BIG DERS' DOG BIRTHDAY.
- YEAH.
- BECAUSE THE DERS' A DOG
AND THEN THERE IS EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENS TO--
- SORRY?
- NOTHING.
- YEAH, HE'S MONKEYING
AROUND AGAIN.
- WHATEVER.
LOOK, UH, THERE'S A BIG SURPRISE
FOR YOU IN THE BREAK ROOM.
IT--IT'S A BIRTHDAY CAKE.
ANYWAY, I'M NOT GOING.
- OKAY.
- ANDERS, WE HAVE A DRESS CODE,
CAN YOU PLEASE?